[Música]
la primera vuelta de las elecciones
legislativas en francia tendrá lugar el
próximo 12 de junio una segunda vuelta
será llevada a cabo el 19 del mismo mes
son elecciones muy importantes para este
país europeo tras el resultado de las
elecciones presidenciales que fueron
celebradas el 24 de abril que confirmó
la continuidad del presidente manuel
marco en el inicio ahora los ciudadanos
franceses deben renovar la asamblea
nacional el órgano legislativo francés
está compuesto por 577 escaños que
representan los 577 distritos
electorales que se dividen de la
siguiente manera
539 son para la francia metropolitana es
decir el territorio continental europeo
francés otros 27 corresponden a los
departamentos y a los territorios de
ultramar como por ejemplo la guyana
francesa la isla de la reunión o las
islas de sant pierre y miquelón entre
otros territorios que hay franceses en
el caribe en el pacífico y en el océano
índico 11 escaños son para los franceses
residentes en el extranjero que es tal
vez el punto que nos reúne para el
programa de hoy
específicamente qué misión tienen estos
representantes de la diáspora francesa
qué peso tienen a nivel político quiénes
son los que aspiran a estos escaños y
qué temas son los que interesan a los
franceses que están en el exterior en el
caso de américa que es el continente en
el que nos encontramos y que nos compete
para estos procesos electorales o un
proceso electoral como este de las
elecciones legislativas dependiendo de
la cantidad de ciudadanos franceses
residentes en los diferentes países del
mundo pues el planeta fue dividido en
diferentes circunscripciones siendo la
primera la que compromete a dos países
muy importantes eeuu y canadá en donde
están tal vez las diásporas francesas
más grandes de todo el continente
americano la segunda circunscripción
corresponde a méxico américa central
caribe y américa del sur es un total de
33 países
es sin duda alguna una circunscripción
importante son 33 estados los que están
ahí en esa segunda circunscripción por
eso es importante pero primero para
entender la importancia del voto de los
extranjeros o de los franceses en el
exterior en estas legislativas hay que
entender pues cuáles son los motivos que
los llevan a votar cuáles son los puntos
que tienen en común con los ciudadanos
franceses que están en europa con
también con los ciudadanos de los que
ellos son partes de esas sociedades en
los diferentes países de américa latina
como es el votante estando lejos de la
francia continental y cómo se ve la
coyuntura política francesa desde fuera
hoy en este episodio llamaría yo muy
pedagógico en el debate de france 24 los
franceses eligen desde américa para
analizar este tema saludamos al señor
ventral tú ponte el ex presidente de la
unión de los ciudadanos franceses en
brasil es candidato a la asamblea
nacional por la unión de la derecha
centro e independientes también está con
nosotros eleonor cagua ella es candidata
de la asamblea nacional por la segunda
circunscripción que corresponde a mexico
américa caribe y suramérica por el grupo
ensemble y en el estudio de france 24
nos acompaña a cristian rodríguez él es
candidato también a la asamblea nacional
de la unión de la izquierda nueva unión
popular ecológica y social ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden
participar en este debate con todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas las pueden
hacer a través de las redes sociales no
se encuentran en facebook en instagram
también estamos en twitter estamos como
france24
s
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal y
les recuerdo nuestra etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en torno a
este tema comienza entonces por el
primer invitado que presenté por
bertrand preguntándole como ya lo decía
yo haciendo un poco de pedagogía
entendiendo un poco cómo son estos
procesos de las elecciones legislativas
en francia- bertrand es bienvenido al
programa muchas gracias por acompañarnos
aquí en el debate de france 24 y
comencemos por lo básico las funciones
que tienen estos diputados para los
franceses en el extranjero hablo de esas
11 curules específicas ciudadanos de la
diáspora
buenas noches gracias por invitarme la
función de un entendía que hay 12
senadores de los franceses
y viven fuera del país y 11 diputados
por es nuestra función
es una función dupla uno es presentar a
nuestros compatriotas que viven en
américa latina y los caribes que tienen
problemáticas específicas
como pueden ser el acceso a los
consulados pueden ser el acceso a la
educación la parte de la parte fiscal
como renovar un
pasaporte y obviamente las
plazas problemáticas
de ayudas sociales los emprendedores y
la
financiación de las empresas pequeñas y
medianas en el continente
toda la parte de acuerdos bilaterales
entre francia y países de la región que
permiten facilitar la vida de ambos
compatriotas franceses pero también de
los de los ciudadanos de los países
donde que nos que nos reciben si los
temas son un instrumento extremadamente
amplio si tenemos una u otra función que
es la función de legislar para
para las leyes en francia se apoya del
gobierno o no dependiendo de las fechas
la bienvenida ahora a él yo no para
conocer su opinión y también para
terminar de despejar y armar este
rompecabezas como punto de partida para
este programa las funciones de estos
diputados a modo
un poco abuelo de pájara lo que ve uno
es como que es una función que va entre
un puente entre parís y los diferentes
países un ir un poco más allá de
simplemente la representación
diplomática o los
empresarios que se encuentran afincados
en los diferentes países hablo de
empresarios franceses esto entonces
juega un poco más por mantener derechos
también como por garantizar algunos
derechos franceses aún estando fuera
como lo ve usted el león o
totalmente muchas gracias por la
invitación a los diputados de los
franceses en el extranjeros que se
presentan a los franceses que son
franceses 'apagón' que ya no sea
enteramente franceses y que tienen esa
suerte porque no existe en todos los
países de tener representantes propios
como lo acaba de decir mi contrincante
obviamente tienen ese de ese deber de
representación de los franceses de su
circunscripción pero votan las leyes
como usted lo dijo yo soy la candidata
por o son mayor intención 100 o sea que
yo soy la candidata por la mayoría
presidencial y el rol principal de la
diputada que entiendo sea si los
franceses me acuerdan su confianza es
votar las leyes y permitir a jimena
contener un peso fuerte poder reformar
el país y seguir la transformación es
por la cual fue electo hace
interesante ese punto de vista del yo no
he aquí en el estudio france24 está con
nosotros cristian rodríguez también para
ayudarnos a entender un poco más de este
proceso electoral de las legislativas y
esas circunscripciones en el extranjero
cristian muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en el estudio y ustedes
vienen de diferentes países y están en
diferentes puntos de la geografía del
continente americano supongo que también
los temas de los franceses en los
diferentes países varían desde su punto
de vista desde la experiencia que usted
tiene cuáles son esos temas que les
interesan a los franceses que están
fuera de las fronteras francesas
muy buenas tardes mucho gusto de estar
con ustedes muchas gracias por la
invitación por supuesto santiago te
responde inmediatamente
yo creo que
la cantidad de franceses y francesas que
viven en toda américa latina y en el
mundo tiene preocupaciones comunes con
ciertas especialidades por supuesto pero
el tema de la educación fundamental que
que hago con mis hijos y qué tipo de
educación le entrego es un tema clave la
preocupación por el estado de la
educación y la mejor educación francesa
segundo tiene que ver mucho con el tema
de la jubilación esta es una población
que tiene también una particularidad que
son franceses que se han instalado a
veces por mucho más de 20 años y que el
tema de la jubilación les preocupa así
como el acceso a la salud también y la
cantidad de
elementos que hacen parte de la vida
para ser feliz cada uno de nosotros la
ecología es un tema fundamental pero hay
algo que yo quiero poner la atención que
el tema del acceso a los servicios
públicos el sentirse francés significa
un consulado a mano significa una
presencia de alto nivel de funcionario
que su misión es el servicio a la
comunidad en este caso y un quinto tema
que ningún francés ni francesa está
fuera de la realidad local
por lo tanto vivir en américa latina'
también da un contexto particular estoy
en colombia justamente porque pronto
aquí hay elecciones y creo que la vida
de los franceses también está ligada a
las situaciones de cada país claro que
sí por ser ciudadanos así sean
temporales están en los diferentes
países de américa latina retomó la ronda
vuelvo a buenos aires bertran para
conocer su punto de vista sobre los
temas que importan a los franceses aquí
hablamos de educación jubilación los
servicios básicos también las garantías
del estado francés en estos territorios
a través de los consulados y las
embajadas que más podemos ver y
profundizar en términos de política
equidad y trabajo desde su punto de
vista
bueno
las preocupaciones son múltiples porque
en los últimos años tuvimos un abandono
de
muchos consulados debido al corte de
presupuestos entonces se simplificó una
serie de
trámites pero se cortó el acceso
cotidiano a los consulados y para
nosotros
el consulado es el punto central de la
vida nuestra y es también el punto
central junto con las embajadas del
contacto con el país que nos que nos
recibe como un dijo que visión es una
cosa que es totalmente integrada tenemos
problemas grandes efectivamente y de
reconocimiento de derechos por ejemplo
aspectos fiscales algunos países tienen
convenciones fiscales con francia otros
no nosotros pagamos impuestos que son
individuos porque en francia todos los
franceses tienen acceso a un hacer
gratuita nosotros no de lo mismo así
pagamos un impuesto que se llama se
refiere a 10
quien cenaron votos tres veces para para
suprimirlo y la mayoría no entonces
tenemos algún problema de equidad y de
iu y un aspecto fundamental tanto para
entonces es como para américa latina es
el tema de educación de la calidad de la
educación de la del acceso
a los liceos a las alianzas a los
institutos franceses y tú y yo hemos
cortes 500 y 12
cargos y profesores en el mundo tenemos
un problema grande ahora para encontrar
profesores porque faltan 300 profesores
para la vuelta
a los cursos en septiembre entonces
entonces yo me lo vivo hace 26 años en
américa latina 8 años en argentina 18
años en brasil y yo vivo eso esos
problemas el tiempo entero como por
ejemplo el cierre de cuenta bancaria
para los franceses en francia por
problemas de compliance que generalmente
no sólo justifica los justificados
entonces necesitan un diputado que
realmente es serra de de aquí que
conozca las preocupaciones que lucha con
año
al lado de ellos desde desde muchos años
como durante la crisis del cobismo claro
el yo no su perspectiva sobre este tema
bertrand habla de ese recorte de algunos
presupuestos en el retiro de algunos
funcionarios en el área de educación de
los liceos franceses o de las alianzas
entonces se convierte en estos diputados
en ese mecanismo para poder hacer
exigencias a los a las autoridades en
francia continental para retornar
digamos esos presupuestos y volverá a
tener los niveles pre pandemia
sí bueno lo que se ha dicho no es del
todo exacto ha habido un aumento de esa
red de liz o frases de que es una red
única en el mundo hay más de 500 listas
francesas a través del mundo y ha habido
continuamente en france un objetivo de
aumentarlo de hecho el presidente manuel
majo tiene un objetivo horizonte 2030 de
doblar los efectivos para permitir el
acceso a familias también nos francesas
dentro de sus liceos durante el cover
wachovia hubo digamos una disminución
que fue temporal pero hubo todo un
mecanismo de ayuda para permitir a las
familias tanto franceses como mensajeras
que supiera mantener en ese sistema yo
soy un producto de ese sistema o sea yo
hice toda mi escolaridad desde prekinder
que es la petición metro nel hasta la
termina de luz el bachiller en el liceo
francés de santo domingo y ahora soy
madre de ese mismo liceo mis hijos están
en el elíseo y veo como el liceo ya más
que la embajada o al mismo nivel que la
embajada por la comunidad yo lo que
quisiera como diputada es permitirle a
más familias francesas que tengan acceso
a liceos y a tasas aceptables y para eso
no hay que tener
de soluciones pragmáticas y para eso
también hay que ser un diputado tenía
peso porque no hay que mentir si no
todos los diputados tienen el mismo peso
en asamblea hay que ser un conjunto
coherente como se dijo somos 11
diputados de planes extranjeros tenemos
preocupaciones que son comunes y tenemos
que trabajar juntos para seguir haciendo
lo que ya se ha hecho y que se ha hecho
en el buen sentido eso con la educación
a mí los temas que es de lo que se han
hablado de lo que han hablado y cristian
y personó me parecen extremadamente
importante pero me parecen importantes
los temas nacionales porque de nuevo
somos diputados de la nación y a mí el
tema que a nivel personal además de la
educación más me preocupa interesa y que
es la raíz de mi de mi vocación política
es la ecología que nosotros tenemos que
lograr la transición energética francia
se está posicionando con un líder en la
transición energética y nosotros los
resultados del extranjero y sobre todo
lo que seamos de américa latina tenemos
un rol esencial que jugar es porque hay
muchas cosas que se pueden hacer por
ejemplo a la base empresarial
empresarios franceses en américa latina
en el sector del desarrollo sostenible
para apoyar para lograr que los
embajadores de francia a través del
continente logramos los objetivos que
nos hemos fijado en esa mayoría
vamos a hablar de esos temas
precisamente lo que ustedes proponen y
de la coyuntura política que está
viviendo francia y también del papel de
francia a nivel global en esta región en
américa latina ya vamos con eso en la
agenda lo tengo pendientes ya lo vamos a
desarrollar y bueno pues comenzó
entonces preguntándole a cristian aquí
en el estudio de france 24 cuáles son
los temas que ustedes proponen desde el
ala de la izquierda que ha sido un
movimiento que ha tenido un interesante
desarrollo en las últimas semanas con
las coaliciones que se han ido armando
con los diferentes partidos se vieron
digamos muy separados en las
presidenciales pero se han logrado
reunir para estas parlamentarias y están
decididos a tener la mayor cantidad de
escaños posibles en nuestra estrategia
de la llamada tercera vuelta la vuelta
legislativa porque buscamos ser
mayoritaria más mayoritarios en la
asamblea legislativa ahora interesante
escuchar porque aparecen malanca agudas
dice
y seguir haciendo más de lo mismo
durante estos cinco años que vienen de
avecinarse
macro no fue una fatalidad los cinco
años anteriores en torno al balance que
tienen y yo creo que no hay que
confundir a nuestros auditores sobre lo
que ha pasado no solamente en el campo
de américa latina pero lo que ha pasado
como bien lo dice somos diputados y
queremos ser diputado representante de
nuestro pueblo a nivel nacional y eso
implica terminar lo que ha sido la
destrucción completa por ejemplo en el
tema de educación aquí hay un doble
estándar en no solamente en el tema
local pero a nivel de la educación
nacional
evidentemente muchos profesores han
sufrido muchos niños han ido cada vez
siendo más excluidos porque han
confundido la educación nacional con la
empresa siguen manejando un país como si
fuera una startup y eso lo que nosotros
no queremos y cuando decimos nosotros no
queremos estamos hablando del programa
que el pueblo francés y llegó a votar
por más de 22 por ciento del programa
que se llama el futuro en común
y esa es nuestra guía esa es nuestra
propuesta
enriquecida y sumada con todas las
fuerzas de la izquierda y con las
fuerzas de ecología porque porque
profundamente es un proyecto social
humanitario y ecológico hay que decirlo
porque en el balance que tenemos de los
5 años yo creo que
el señor macro no es el más ecológico y
espero que los que pretenden ser sus
diputados no se califiquen de esa
ambición porque la convención
ecológica mundial misión macro ni no lo
digo yo lo dicen toda la asociación
ecológica fue una fatalidad con mucho
bla bla pero muy pocas cosas en concreto
entonces la con las cosas concretas que
nosotros estamos planteando tienen que
ver con una defensa de una educación con
un mejoramiento de concreto de cada día
en torno a una escuela accesible para
todos los franceses en el mundo y
también acá tiene que ver con parar el
tema de los profesores
o sea hay una cantidad de medida que
podemos pasar un largo rato explicándolo
pero lo que yo quiero fundamentalmente
decir aquí no podemos hacer como no ha
pasado absolutamente nada aquí es la
candidata de macro tiene que dar cuenta
de por ejemplo una diputada del
tiempo tengo que darle la palabra otras
dos personas en leonora leo no tiene
espacio para una réplica ya le dé la
palabra a bertrand
previamente yo lo que quiero presentar
acá es que tenemos que salir de las
ideologías y tenemos que ver cuáles son
las soluciones pragmáticas que podemos
encontrar para los problemas que
encuentra francia y que encuentra el
mundo yo no dije que se va a hacer cinco
años más de lo mismo yo dije que se han
hecho muchas cosas muy positivas también
a nivel de educación se pudiera pasar un
debate entero hablando de eso de lo que
se está haciendo para que nuestros niños
tengan una mejor educación en educación
de calidad una educación más y
permissions con la reforma que ha habido
pero sobre todo en relación a la
ecología hay una orientación clara que
fue dada que los franceses adoptaron al
votar de nuevo premio del manco' hace
unas semanas y yo como diputada de las
mayorías y me dije voy a asegurarme de
defender ese tema porque es un tema que
a mí a nivel personaje de nosotros
diputado en la mayoría es muy importante
eso lo que quería precisar la ideología
del programa sólo un segundo
como por ejemplo un impuesto sobre la
nacionalidad que sería una aberración
para ciudadanos por ejemplo de la
argentina que ya tiene
los problemas que son propios con la
devaluación que ganan a veces en pesos
que realmente mirar cada medida una por
una y tratar de encontrar lo que es
justo y lo que justo no siempre es lo
que vídeo
pero tanto algún comentario
las palabras
son muy lindas pero
yo estoy de rectoría cuando por otras
personas que el momento de marcar fue un
desastre la deuda se fue se fue para
despacio como los tenemos un problema de
una necesidad de descentralización en
francia muy grande tenemos un país
tenemos los hospitales en las
universidades en las escuelas un
problema de
seguridad en la calle y los problemas
son graves
lo vimos con los cigarros de la sociedad
francesa es efectivamente fracturada hoy
y hay que unir y no separar las personas
como se hizo durante los los cinco
últimos años cristiano estaba hablando
la diputada actual que también fue
electa por el
marco totalmente de la aparición y
se presentó para las elecciones
municipales en un barrio de aríz
entonces
nosotros somos son los titulados un poco
atípicos porque defendemos nuestros
compatriotas tenemos que defendernos en
sus compatibles que viven lejos y
también obviamente claro defendían
nuestro país
la manera de ser de francia lo que fue y
lo que queremos que es que sea y la
ideología de mccomb durante cinco años
fue un parlamento mandamiento que
simplemente fue una cámara registradora
no no hubo
planeta pero ni los diputados bertrand
entonces cuáles son las propuestas desde
su bancada política desde el espectro
que usted representa
como de
nuestro agrado obviamente que la parte
de climática es importante pero tenemos
que hacer reformas la reforma de la
fundación es indispensable la reforma de
la universidad para dar más más
autonomías pero no no más autonomías
para dejar el privado entrar pero para
que haya más creatividad
cómo orientar la educación para temas
futuros que permitan adaptar la
educación a las necesidades del mercado
también le vert esa y esa crítica con
europa marcón quiere una europa
federalista yo soy europeo pero soy para
una europa de las naciones tenemos que
reformar el hospital y no cerrar camas
como como se hizo durante el beat y lo
que faltó mucho durante los cinco años y
lo vimos durante el cubrir que este
gobierno siempre corre atrás y gobernaba
es es prever el futuro claro
para cerrar esta ronda y para terminar
de conocer las propuestas de los
diferentes candidatos termina entonces
con el lyon auge en la ciudad de
santiago en chile propuestas temas
importantes de los que usted quiere
destacar
bueno yo quisiera también responder a lo
que se ha dicho se ha se ha hecho muchas
cosas en el pilón de mccomb es bastante
positivo sobre muchos aspectos
trabajamos dos crisis y obviamente eso
ha tenido un impacto pero hoy hay un
programa solo igual del pro franceses
decidieron de las apoyos a no todos
obviamente la idea es gobernar para
todos pero este programa implica una
serie de medidas muy fuertes que van a
tener que ser tomadas de pared
necesitamos una estabilidad fuerte con
la asamblea que respondan una asamblea
que defienda también a los ciudadanos yo
soy una verdadera francesa en el
extranjero o sea yo soy franco
dominicana como los dos tercios de los
franceses que residen en el continente
latinoamericano
tengo esa mi nacionalidad como les decía
ser un producto también del sistema de
educación francés y para mí es esencial
defenderlo y permitir que las familias
tengan acceso a eso a nivel nacional y
le hablaba de la ecología porque para mí
la ecología tiene que ser nuestro
horizonte a todos y en base a eso se
tiene que reformar la sociedad europa o
sea
lo que más ha hecho por europa en lo que
se ha tenido que hacer en estos últimos
meses
hecho con la presidencia francesa ha
sido en el buen sentido y tenemos que
seguir adelante tenemos que seguir
continuando somos franceses no todos
aquí alrededor de esta mesa los
franceses somos monos como decimos
estamos en desacuerdo con una serie de
cosas pero es lo que se está viendo lo
que estamos haciendo hay mucho positivo
no todo por eso necesitamos un
parlamento fuerte pero realmente tenemos
que salvar lo que hay e ir hacia
adelante de nuevo se trata de la
identidad es una candidata magmática y
quiero defender a los franceses en el
extranjero sin americana
hablemos ahora de la coyuntura que está
atravesando francia en este momento voy
a hacer la ronda a la inversa entonces
continuó con berta en la ciudad de
buenos aires para conocer su opinión la
perspectiva que hay de ciudadanos que
llevan ya mucho tiempo viendo por fuera
del país que ya están asentados en el
caso de bertrand en suramérica la
coyuntura del país como ve el liderazgo
de francia a nivel mundial como ve el
liderazgo de francia dentro de la unión
europea con la coyuntura que hay la
salida del reino unido de la unión
europea la guerra en ucrania el distante
miento con rusia y la situación
económica que atraviesa prácticamente a
todas las naciones después de la
pandemia del cob y 19 cuál es su
perspectiva
francia está perdiendo espacio en el
debate internacional yo creo que francia
tiene un mensaje para el mundo que tiene
que que ya llevo para el mundo y tiene
que continuar redondo porque estamos en
un momento de crisis estamos un momento
de guerra es la primera vez que tenemos
una guerra a las fronteras europea
dentro de la unión europea
y dijimos es una cosa buena a nivel de
europa que todos sus países se unieron
para defender un país que fue claramente
agredido ahora y eso es importante que
nosotros estemos dentro del auto pero
que queríamos un sistema dentro de
europa con lados propia y yo no veo
marco hacer eso porque no lo hizo vimos
para casos diplomáticos como por ejemplo
con los submarinos en
nuestra área en el mal y es él el balón
sobre el del mandato marco a nivel
internacional es es exponerlo y si lo
tomamos sobre américa latina mccone fue
presidente que menos vino en el
continente ok work uvi pero un mandato
dura cinco años sea decimos la relación
entre francia y brasil tenemos tenemos
el asunto qué
y continúa siendo estudiado entre entre
mercosur y la unión europea tenemos una
realidad de un
continente y américa latina ama francia
y nosotros traigamos hoy por hoy a la
altura de de
lo que podemos hacer juntos mismo
teniendo empresas que emplean un montón
de
personas en sus países algunas llevarán
los valores del país o los mayores en
empleados claro ya que en el estudio
france24 cristian su perspectiva como de
la coyuntura del país el liderazgo a
nivel internacional sobre todo
yo creo que
en nuestra perspectiva
[Música]
nosotros necesitamos una francia no
alineada una francia que sea respetada y
que pueda tomar de nuevo su puesto
fundamental de lo que era en el mundo lo
que era lo digo porque comparto con esta
visión de que hemos perdido
absolutamente en mucho terreno en el
mundo internacional porque hemos tratado
de llevar a una a una radicalidad y una
oposición entre los buenos y los malos
yo creo que francia merece mucho más que
eso tiene que ser extremadamente no
alineada extremadamente
altermundialista en nuestra visión de
las cosas sobre esta francia que en el
mundo entero tan ha sido reconocida
ahora
cuando hablaba recién madame que aboga
sobre el tema de la noy de
ideologización de del trabajo de los
diputados me daba en mi cabeza pensaba
si los más de 11 millones de pobres
inscritos en el en polvo amplo a más de
66 millones de franceses
tienen que acceder a la ayuda
alimenticia hoy día
son cliente exista ideologizada o no yo
creo que hay un balance concreto quien
nefasto lo insisto y qué macrón no hizo
campaña en torno a un programa macro no
hizo campaña en torno hagan ustedes más
de lo mismo y voten por mí porque yo voy
a venir aquí a hacer la reforma que todo
aún no ha terminado cuáles son esas
reformas que aún no han terminado
terminar de vender el país lo poco que
queda en privatizar lo absolutamente y
del pacto el pactar el paquete grande de
lo que aún queda en el tema la jubile
jude y la jubilación la verdad es que se
dice no nosotros queremos una red de 60
años si usted quiere jubilar a los 67 68
vote por macrón en eso fuimos muy claro
si nosotros llevan una mayoría al
parlamento una mayoría de la nueva unión
popular ecológica y social no es
ideología es un proyecto basado en las
aspiraciones para mejorar la vida cada
uno de nosotros y eso tiene que
decidirlo el pueblo con sus votos tiene
que decidirlo cada ciudadano con su voto
por lo tanto no es un tema de mayor o
menor ideología es un tema de poder
confrontar a los verdaderos problemas
que hay hoy día en nuestra sociedad y
que discúlpenme macrón no fue elegido
mayoritariamente
ese de ello es el que tiene peor es el
peor elegido en la quinta república
mccraw gana porque nadie quería a la
extrema derecha pero no significa una
adhesión a un programa que no lo
conocemos porque fue elegido con un
programa el pasado de los 5 años clave
la palabra a leónov para conocer su
opinión sobre la coyuntura política del
país también el tema económico se me
escapa mencionarlo pero pues es un tema
transversal mundial por la pandemia de
kobe 19 y también para momento de
réplica para los otros dos invitados
muchas gracias efectivamente un poquito
de réplica acá por que tomemos ejemplos
concretos estamos hablando del acuerdo
unión europea-mercosur que fue frenado
últimamente porque porque teníamos que
hacer más psicología porque tenemos que
ser más exigente sobre lo que hacemos
bajo fue elegido en base a un programa y
lo siento contrariamente a - jon que
llega de terceros y que se autoproclama
primer ministro el presidente de francia
hoy es el presidente que fue electo por
los franceses y hasta nuevo aviso
estamos en una democracia yo considero
que hoy tenemos muchos desafíos que son
desafíos globales nosotros los que somos
aspirantes a ser candidatos diputados
para las clases en el extranjero tenemos
un rol muy particular que llevar y de
nuevo un rol no ideológico y discúlpeme
pero estamos hablando de no alineados
estamos hablando con terminología de los
años 60 que fueron sueños y que yo los
respeto con los años de mis padres pero
hoy miren ustedes hablan de feminismo
pero los candidatos que presentan en
realidad son candidatos que están
desconectados del terreno cuando bien
por ejemplo mujeres hubiera podido ser
presentada es una mujer abogada de 36
años y conozco perfectamente este
continente que depende del estado en
este continente y que defenderá las
relaciones entre américa latina y
francia en el parlamento francés si me
acuerdo en su confianza
o si tienen rápidamente porque me quedan
muy pocos minutos para terminar el
programa
la coyuntura económica hemos hecho lo
que nunca se había hecho hemos hecho el
cual quiero y hemos ayudado a miles de
empresas en clase en el exterior hemos
entrado a miles de familias a seguir con
sus hijos en los liceos franceses en el
extranjero hemos hecho una política muy
de izquierda pero al mismo tiempo
plasmáticas hoy me importa es encontrar
soluciones y cuando yo veo que mis
contrincantes que apoyan a gobiernos
como los demás como los de chávez
etcétera se permiten darme lecciones
sobre sobre el pragmatismo yo pienso que
deberíamos de hablar un juego de que
queremos hacer y me quieran llevan muy
pocos minutos para terminar el programa
rápidamente les quiero preguntar
justamente por la relación entre los
países de donde ustedes
vienen o residen y la relación con
francia como ven que pueda mejorar la
relación dada pues la pandemia de kobe
19 nos ha permitido prácticamente
retomar un poco la normalidad en
comercio y en desplazamientos y hasta en
turismo pero cómo puede mejorarse la
relación entre francia y sudamérica en
este caso comienzo entonces por bertrand
rápidamente por favor porque me quedan
muy pocos minutos
como como se puede mejorar creo que el
diputado tiene una función muy grande en
conexión con las autoridades locales
cuando estuve en colombia hay elecciones
ahora subir gente del partido real de
paz socialista del centro de la derecha
y eso estoy aquí hace muchísimos tiempos
en muchas conexiones que van a facilitar
eso ahora quiero quiero ya que estamos
acá donde negativamente por favor si
quiero hacer una observación porque
parece que yo no soy pragmático para
eleonor aquí no conozco de qué estoy
hablando yo vivo aquí de o no para de
hablar que era volvió a vivir en américa
latina' entoces tengo una pregunta para
ella
tú vas a poder votar para ti mismo
l no era rápidamente alguna respuesta
no todo el programa por favor
y yo quiero reiterar de verdad que yo
soy una francesa de
personales y de hecho no entiendo que
me queda un minuto para cerrar el
programa por favor cristian rápido
porque debo dar paso al noticiero quiere
ser diputado de la nación no significa
hay que contarnos una especie de mitin a
esto encuentro amoroso quienes más
tienen menos yo no estoy en esa
perspectiva no tengo para que
desarrollar quién es mi hijo etcétera lo
que yo quiero un programa y el debate
que yo tengo que tener aquí es sobre lo
que quiere los franceses en américa
latina y el caribe por lo tanto con una
abogada suiza con mucho respeto que nos
venga a manifestar quienes más tienen
menos yo pienso que los franceses
nuestros votantes van a estar con
nosotros y van a poder lograr lo que
queremos una asamblea de mayoría para
todos cristian qué pena cortarlo ustedes
entienden los temas de televisión de bar
pasó el informativo usted siga con
nosotros gracias a los invitados para
ver estado con nosotros
[Música]